un punto de inflexión para la ciencia en
el camino hacia la obtención de energía
limpia y casi limitada
en pocas palabras Esta es una de las
hazañas científicas más impresionantes
del siglo XXI
Los investigadores de Lawrence Livermore
National laboratory de California han
logrado demostrar que la ganancia neta
de energía mediante la fusión nuclear es
posible uniendo átomos de hidrógeno y
obteniendo más energía de la fusión de
sus núcleos que la invertida por los
lásers que los calentaron a más de tres
millones de grados Celsius la semana
pasada por primera vez diseñaron el
experimento de forma que El combustible
se mantuvo suficientemente caliente
tenso y compacto durante suficientemente
tiempo como para aprenderse y generó más
energía de la que los láses depositaron
cerca de 2 MB invertidos por cerca de 3
mega youlls obtenidos una ganancia de
alrededor del 50 por ciento
la fusión es la reacción que tiene lugar
en el interior de las Estrellas y que
las hace brillar Desde que la humanidad
lo entendió ha intentado replicar el
proceso de forma controlada en un
laboratorio con proyectos que cooperan y
compiten alrededor del mundo A
diferencia de la afición nuclear que
obtiene la energía a base de la división
de átomos de elementos pesados como el
uranio y generar residuos peligrosos por
su radioactividad la fusión nuclear es
prácticamente limpia y requiere
hidrógeno uno de los elementos más
abundantes en nuestro planeta tras este
primerito aún quedan otros por alcanzar
y el camino será largo el segundo hito
es como hacerlo de manera barata digamos
Es decir de manera competitiva para
lograr eso todavía falta falta mucho
están hablando de una década década y
media para que esto pueda lograrse de
manera masiva se requiere que además sea
barato estamos todavía un poquito lejos
de eso pero para la humanidad diez años
no estando un logro que ofrece
esperanzas de frenar la crisis climática
y alterar el mapa geo político de la
dependencia energética mundial